everyone to commit Foley and you know I
want to he's my best friend Jennifer
Lawrence is ready to say I do
why is cook the one he's just the best
person I've ever met in my whole life it
was it was a very easy easy decision
j-law got engaged to art galleries cook
Maroney in February and now the actress
is opening up about planning her
upcoming nuptials dishing on the naked
with Catt Sadler podcast so I haven't
been like neurotic about it I'm a little
bit I'm like too lazy to be neurotic I
like saw dress I liked I was like that's
the dress I saw penny was a cool we got
the venue but Jen did admit to having
one bridezilla moment when she thought
she didn't want a bachelorette party but
changed her mind and none of her friends
were available because it was too
last-minute I didn't realize it I wanted
it until yesterday until I realized I
couldn't have it like my friend was like
welcome to being a bride yeah
and now I've cried and you know I feel
like I've joined a fish alia joined the
club Jennifer also talked about meeting
cook and taking a break from her career
I feel like I got to kind of guess it's
gonna sound awful I got to know myself
in the past year but um it was great you
know I met somebody I fell in love and
I've started a new life in New York it's
not as private as I was literate to be
but I've just been I've been doing
things that I didn't actually think that
I could
the Oscar winner explains that she used
to feel like she couldn't go out due to
her fame but that all changed when she
started dating cook I used to like have
a stigma about you know I would get
nervous before going to like restaurants
or I felt like I couldn't go to dive
bars they were just like certain things
that I was just like oh I can't do that
and then the past year I've just been
doing all of them honestly do you think
somebody didn't want to tell him about
like my you know I wanted to be like
normal and I didn't want to be like you
know I didn't want a sermon so yeah so I
just kind of hid that part of me and
then everything ended up being fine
Jennifer says her relationship with cook
developed organically and she admits she
wasn't in a place where she was ready to
get married until she met him I just met
cook and I and I wanted to marry him I
we wanted to marry each other he's the
greatest person I've ever
so I feel very honored to become Moroni
and get this she plans to legally change
her last name to his I want to legally
bind him to me forever so unfortunately
the paperwork exists for such a thing
it's the greatest you find your favorite
person on the planet you're like you
can't leave so I wanted to take up on
that offer a source recently told the et
that the lovebirds are quote
head-over-heels in love and have been
truly inseparable since their engagement